I have to say I watched your movie the
watch the other night I very much
enjoyed it and I was kind of blown away
there's a there's some action scenes
there's some running scenes where it's
clearly not stunt-double where you're
hauling ass
this guy is an amazing shape unless
you're using some kind of crazy CGI that
I don't know about no I know I am I just
try to run like Tom Cruise I think he is
the ultimate Runner really that's who
you're channeling do kind of open-handed
run yes and I can do it for like about
15 yards and then I get out of gas right
did you I mean you're clearly though
you're you're you're on some kind of
regimen or something I am Greg carrier
oh thank you thank you I made uh I made
some dietary change I quit I quit coffee
you quit coffee yes is that hard to do
it is hard to do I just I just realized
I got to you know an age in life where
I'd love to get headaches and it's
really hard though it took like a month
or so before you know really they say it
takes like at least a couple of weeks to
to like sort of yet to get it okay yeah
it only takes like three days to kick
heroin the coffee's like two weeks and
when you kick heroin people are like oh
that's great man congratulations you got
your life together right and then you
know you quit coffee and it's like all
right want some tea here but it's really
hard and I also and then I started to
eat vegan oh you're a vegan now well I
don't like calling myself a vegan but I
I feel like yeah it's weird to be called
you don't like that feel like it puts
you in it like it's it's strange you
know people look at you strangely I had
to tell my parents I was a vegan mm-hmm
I came out to them they were a little
bit confused at first when I was
supportive oh that's nice that's nice
yeah actually technically because I'd
like to have fish so you like fish yes I
have some fish and I guess so I guess I
guess I'm what they call a pescetarian
is that what it's called a pescetarian a
person who eats fish is a pescetarian
sounds like a weird Protestant religion
it's like based on fish or something
I was raised Methodist but now I'm a
seventh-day pescetarian but I get so
excited yeah I can't like do it you miss
then do you mean like like you know how
do you feel do you feel a lot better now
that you are not drinking coffee you're
only eating fish oh I feel awful tell
you that vegans don't tell you is that
it's hard because you you miss
everything I miss I want I ate kale
chips today what really that was what I
ate I wanted to I want to have ribs but
I had kale chips and then they tell you
you can have sort of you know you can
have things to substitute like instead
of a cheeseburger you could have like a
hummus burger right with nut cheese on
it
yeah well you have the nut cheese hummus
burger a lot of that cheese in my life I
don't like it when they try and build
the food that you really want out of the
food that you don't want yeah just eat
the hummus or eat the kale but don't
construct right a hamburger right out of
kale yeah you know exactly like a raw
almond nut cheese lasagnas just leave it
alone yes now you have you have two
children I mean if your children are a
little older than mine are they have
been acting do they have the acting bug
they they like they're they're very
dramatic and they like to play around
but they're not like interested in it
professionally I hope not
you don't want them to act I don't know
I mean like I want them to be happy you
know but my daughter does plays at
school she just did
production she's 10 they did a
production of A Chorus Line at school of
course yes which is kind of a little bit
of a heavy play for 10 year olds
it's about jaded New York dancers who
want to get into show business right and
they were all like maybe on the brink of
yeah making it yeah it was a great
production it was really it was really
well done they did great but just to see
like you know a little 10 year olds
belting out what I did for love
you know and they haven't even hit
puberty yet just here but my daughter
was great in it she was really good it's
just it's just weird to just you know
seek to play like their their cynical
yes yes because she was boozy and full
of regrets she really nailed it happy
ten years